SHORT?
[CHEERS & APPLAUSE]
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
STOP IT.
THE WORLD IS LOOKING GOOD.
NORTH KOREA IS CALMING DOWN.
NO ISIS.
UNEMPLOYMENT AT ITS LOWEST IN
AGES.
TRUMP HAD A GREAT MEETING WITH
THAT NIGERIAN GUY.
I THINK HE WROTE ME A LONG
E-MAIL ONCE.
SENT HIM 10 GRAND, NEVER HEARD
FROM HIM AGAIN.
WONDER WHAT HAPPENED.
WHILE THE WORLD IMPROVES, THE
MEDIA FOCUSING ON THE WORST.
THE "THE NEW YORK TIMES" RAN AN
ARTICLE ENTITLED "HAPPY 200th
BIRTHDAY, KARL MARX.
YOU WERE RIGHT ."
BUT WHAT A STRANGE THING TO SAY.
I GUESS THE TRIBUTE TO JOHNS
WILKES BOOTHE WASN'T READY YET.
BUT AS THE WRITER GLORIFIES THE
DEAD COME
DEAD COMIE, WE BELIEVE THE TIMES
DIDN'T GO FAR ENOUGH SO WE
CREATED A REAL SALUTE.
>> HAPPY BIRTHDAY KARL MARX.
RIGHT UP THERE WITH THE YUNA
BOMBER.
IN FACT IT WAS SUCH AN AWESOME
IDEA THAT A BUNCH OF COUNTRIES
TRIED IT, LIKE LENNON'S SOVIET
UNION FEATURES MASS
IMPRISONMENT.
CASTRO'S CUBA FEATURES ANIMAL
FARM EQUIPMENT.
AND VENEZUELA, TOILET PAPER
LINES FOR DAYS.
AND A BUNCH OF COUNTRIES THAT
DON'T EXIST ANYMORE.
AND THERE'S EVEN COMMUNIST
NATIONS AROUND TODAY LIKE NORTH
KOREA BUT THEY WON'T ADMIT IT
BECAUSE IT'S SO SUCCESSFUL THEY
DON'T WANT TO RUB IT IN THE REST
OF THE WORLD'S FACE.
HAPPY 200 BIRTHDAY, BRO.
GREG: WELL DONE.
SO WE JUST WHIPPED THAT
TOGETHER.
SO AS THE WORLD ENTERS AN
OPTIMISTIC AGE, THE MEDIA STILL
CHASES WORDS AND NOT DEEDS.
THE LATEST FREAK OUT, WHAT TRUMP
SAID ABOUT WHAT GIULIANI SAID
ABOUT, YOU GUESSED IT, STORMY.
>> IT WAS STAGGERING.
>> VERY CONFUSING.
>> IT IS ASPHONNISHING.
>> DISGRACEFUL.
>> ASTONISHING.
>> STUNNING.
>> THAT WAS A DISASTER.
>> OTHER MEMBERS OF THE LEGAL
TERM ARE FREAKING OUT.
>>
.>
GREG: WHAT'S WRONG WITH THESE
PEOPLE?
THEY'RE LIKE KIDS WHO ATE ALL OF
THEIR HALLOWEEN CANDY IN ONE
NIGHT.
THEY'RE OVERLOADED.
THEY'RE GOING TO END UP WITH A
DTO, DONALD TRUMP OVERDOSE.
CNN HAS HAD STORMY'S LAWYER ON
60 TIMES IN THREE MONTHS.
HE GETS MORE AIR TIME THAT
POLLEN.
>> YOU GOT TO STOP INTERRUPTING
ME.
>> THE COVERUP IS THE CON.
>> WHOEVER THE ATTORNEY IS WHO
WROTE THOSE TWO TWEETS IS AN
ABSOLUTE MORON.
>> NO DOUBT HE'S GOING TO FLIP
DISWHR YOU
.ISWHR YOU
.>>WHR YOU
.>> YR YOU
.>> YOUYOU
.>> YOU CU
.>> YOU CAN PUT LIPSTICK ON THE
PIG MORNING, NOON AND NIGHT BUT
IT'S STILL GOING TO BE A PIG.
>> I'M STUNNED.
STILL STUNNED THIS MORNING.
GREG: EVERY DAY HE'S SPEECHLESS
WHICH IS WEIRD BECAUSE HE NEVER
SHUTS UP.
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE.
BUT FAIR PLAY TO HIM.
HE'S GOT CNN IN HIS BACK POCKET
AND HE WON'T STOP FARTING.
I THOUGHT ABOUT TAKING THAT OUT.
NOW REMEMBER WHEN IT WAS ALL
ABOUT COLLUSION.
BUT NOW EVEN MSNBC HAS DOUBTS.
THAT IS GREAT.
>> AS FOR THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION, I, I AM VERY, AS
AN AMERICAN, A CITIZEN, I'M
FASCINATED TO KNOW WHAT HE
FINDS.
I'M NOT, I'M NOT SO SURE THAT
HE'S GOING TO FIND THE SMOKING
GUN OF COORDINATION OR
COLLUSION.
GREG: OH MY GOD.
MSNBC NOT SURE ABOUT COLLUSION?
THAT'S LIKE MICHAEL MOORE NOT
SURE ABOUT PIE.
HE LIKES PIE.
CAN'T CHANGE HIS MIND ON PIE.
SO IT'S STORMY THIS AND STORMY
THAT FROM PEOPLE WHO USED TO SAY
WHO CARES, IT'S ONLY SEX.
THE LESSON, IF YOU LOSE AN
ELECTION, WHY NOT SUE
AFTERWARDS.
IT'S THE POLITICAL EQUIVALENT OF
TONYA HARDING TAKING OUT NANCY
KERRIGAN.
AND THE MEDIA AND THE DEMS ARE
SEAN EBBING
SEAN ECKING
SEAN ECKERG
SEAN ECKERT.
THE ECHO IS IMPOACH.
THERE ARE NO DEMOCRATIC IDEAS TO
COUNTER TRUMP'S SUCCESSES.
I MEAN HOW DO THE DEMOCRATS TOP
ENDING THE NORTH KOREA NUCLEAR
THREAT.
WHAT WOULD BE THEIR ISSUES?
FREE HEALTH CARE FOR MS-13?
HORSES SHOULD BE ABLE TO MARRY
SHEEP?
I'M FOR THAT ACTUALLY.
LOVE IS LOVE.
ALL RIGHT.
AND SO IN A SPRINT TRUMP MADE
THE WORLD BETTER FOR 7.6 BILLION
PEOPLE AND THE QUESTION PLAYING
THE MEDIA'S BRAIN, DID A RICH
BILLIONAIRE PLAYBOY LIE ABOUT
SEX.
I THINK I CAN SAVE THEM A YEAR
OF PROGRAMMING TIME AND SAY,
YES.
NEXT QUESTION, DOES AMERICA
CARE?
SEE, YOU CAN LOOK AT THIS LATEST
STORMY STUFF TWO DIFFERENT WAYS.
ONE AS A LAWYER.
TRUMP IS ALLOWED TO PAY A
SETTLEMENT.
DIDN'T USE CAMPAIGN FUNDS.
OR YOU CAN LOOK AT IT AS A
VOTER, YOU CARE MORE ABOUT PEACE
THAN PORN STARS AND DEEDS MORE
THAN WORDS.
THAT BRINGS US TO THIS CHOICE,
DO YOU WANT A WHOLESOME
PRESIDENT WHO COULD NEVER HAVE
FIGURED OUT NORTH KOREA.
I KNOW THE CHOICE I MADE AND
IT'S THE CHOICE AMERICA MADE
ALREADY.
LET US WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST.
HE'S SMART AND TOUGH LIKE AN
ENCYCLOPEDIA THAT CAN KICK YOUR
ASS, FOX NEWS
ASS, SOX NEWS
ASS, SEB NEWS
ASS, SEBASEWS
ASS, SEBASTIS
ASS, SEBASTIAN GORKA.
RETIRED GREEN BERET MASTER
SERGEANT IN STRANGE PANTS, TERRY
SHAPPER.
HER BAC IS ALWAYS HIGHER THAN
HER BMI.